[Applause]
uh congratulations sir thank you
uh well done you because he didn't just
win the world it's your sixth
time winning the world championships
which is i mean an amazing achievement
[Music]
[Applause]
and you have won but the
season isn't over yet yeah okay
because you were so far ahead yeah okay
so i my question i mean maybe this is a
stupid question that
why bother doing the rest of the
that's that's exactly what i like
wouldn't you park up put up the radio
have a greg's just
like i've got it uh bring me the
champagne you know graham
the the seasons are so long we start
training in january testing starts in
february
first race is in march and it goes all
the way in to the beginning of december
so of course i'd love to take a break
yeah i wish kind of wish i didn't have
to do the last two races
however you don't that was my point you
don't need the points because the
championship yeah
and the team championship is done but um
but i still want to win the races you
know and now it's more
it's kind of fun the pressure was on
previously and now these are kind of
more
laid back but in these two races i can
experience and learn some new things
which i can take on to next year but now
that you're the one to beat i guess
you've always been the one to beat for a
while now
do people do the other drivers kind of
treat you differently do you feel under
threat is it more dangerous being you
because they're so desperate to beat you
i don't think no it's not more dangerous
um now now the second oldest driver
there believe it or not
and all you know there's 19 20 year olds
that are that have come in
um but no i honestly i don't i think
naturally i am a target
but my race number when i was eight
years old was number 44.
so even though i am number one and i
have been for the last couple of years
and i should have number one on the car
i keep 44 in there so every year i feel
like i'm just starting a clean slate
and no one's champion but i want to be
the champion does it get harder as you
get older then
does your reaction time go do you get
worse or i'm lucky
no no no but i think a question yeah
that's a really good question now my
reaction times are pretty good
um at the moment still but at some stage
they may obviously drop off so
but you can train still to to sort that
yeah i do think that
there is a point in which you know you
can't keep it up the demand on the
season is so high
the sacrifice that you have to continue
to make to be an opera
and perform at the top of your level
every year it it takes so much time
away from family away from friends and
the sacrifices that you make i mean
there is a point in which you just don't
want to do anymore
you